eu acredito que muitos de vocês ou já
sabem ou fazem idéia de como o primeiro
dia de atendimento às pessoas é um dia
importante na vida acadêmica de um
profissional é de alguém que está
fazendo medicina de um estudante porque
a gente está sentindo um pouquinho
médico já está ali extremo jaleco roupa
branca
eu lembro bem do meu primeiro dia porque
já havíamos falado muito bem do médico
acompanharia que um cara super
inteligente gente boa que eu ia adorar
eu criei todas as melhores expectativas
com relação a esse primeiro dia e eu
lembro que eu cheguei no consultório
realmente foi muito bacana me acolheu e
tudo mais se falou agora luiza nós
precisamos começar o atendimento mas
antes que a gente comece faça me o favor
pegue essa cadeira e leve lá na equipe
de enfermagem por favor eu pensei tudo
bem entregue a cadeira e no caminho
pensava gente mas está faltando cadeira
aqui que as meninas da equipe de
enfermagem pegar o a cadeira que era o
paciente então podemos sentar e na volta
revoltada eu comentei com ele mas que
absurdo essa falta de cadeiras em doutor
ele não tá faltando cadeira que ele na
verdade essa é uma estratégia excelente
já a prenda isso com a gente no hospital
extremamente movimentado
a gente tira a cadeira do paciente que é
pena não ter tempo de sentar conta
longas histórias e rapidamente resume o
motivo da consulta a gente consegue
despachar rápido então do isa leve essa
é aprendizado para a sua vida e eu
confesso que claro a gente não pode
generalizar mas como esse eu tive vários
ensinamentos semelhantes e é óbvio que
eu não levei para minha vida eu queria
alguma coisa diferente e hoje eu sou
médico de família
pra quem não sabe o que o médico de
família pa né
nós somos os médicos que atendem em
postos de saúde em centros de saúde e é
na casa das pessoas a domicílio
nós atendemos em presídios em zonas
rurais isoladas
então nós estamos em vários cenários
diferentes e realmente a minha família
me encantou por exemplo a gente não só
que as pessoas sentem como a gente
realmente quer que elas contém longas
histórias e isso faz diferença pra gente
e existe uma uma forma da gente
organizar o nosso consultório também é
um pouco diferente
a gente tem essa sugestão de disposição
das cadeiras da mesa que não é frente a
frente ela do lado
isso tudo para facilitar a proximidade
com a pessoa que estaria sentada para
deixar que a gente toque nessas pessoas
que a gente realmente crie vínculos se
aproxime dessas pessoas e é isso que nós
na medicina de família queremos isso é
realmente algo encantador bom mas
voltando à universidade
eu segui o caminho que quase todos os
estudantes de medicina seguem durante a
sua vida acadêmica
eu fui monitora de anatomia e depois eu
entrei para a liga de cirurgia mais pra
frente eu fiz um estágio em cirurgia
cardiovascular como assim né ela saiu na
medicina de família mas enfim a minha
vida ea minha sociedade na minha cabeça
estavam definidas logo nos primeiro
semestre da faculdade porque as
monitoria c as ligas elas são muito
interessantes pra gente e aí
com o passar do tempo a gente foi eu fui
observando que eu queria uma coisa um
pouco diferente né então é a gente
observa que cada vez mais nas nossas
universidades
o enfoque da educação é nós nos serviços
de alta complexidade nas urgências e
emergências nos hospitais na alta
tecnologia
em detrimento da atenção básica é da
simplicidade e quando a gente lembra que
é esse enfoque está nessa alta
complexidade
a gente observa que o que é realmente
importante estar perto das pessoas vai
sendo deixado de lado
vocês podem observar que hoje quase
nenhum pediatra é só pediatra ou
cirurgião é só o cirurgião
normalmente o pediatra é endócrino
pediatra nefro pediatra e o cirurgião é
cirurgião de cabeça e pescoço
nessas há necessidade nem na lista estão
diminuindo
e por que é que está acontecendo né
por conta desse foco nas nossas
universidades e dentro da medicina de
família eu senti que estava voltando
àquela medicina das origens é praticando
a medicina que não estuda o corpo humano
em partes
estudou todo bom em 2012
eu criei uma página no facebook que eu
chamei diário de um posto de saúde
essa página é usava pra fazer denúncias
e agora muito revoltada tinha acabado de
me formar e diante daquela estrutura
precária que eu vivia falta de insumos
eu usava esse canal pra isso pra
denunciar mesmo para expor aquilo que
não me agradava e na época tinha uma boa
repercussão foi pra mídia e tudo mais
conseguir melhorias para a unidade onde
eu trabalhava mas realmente foi sempre
algo muito local e claro eu revoltada
expõe as coisas mas dava poucas soluções
e com o passar dos anos eu fui
amadurecendo nem foi vivenciando a
medicina de família criando nas minhas
as minhas experiências e esse
amadurecimento
eu percebo que se deu principalmente com
a história da dona joana a dona joana
era uma senhora de mais ou menos 50 anos
de idade dona de casa e tímida bem
recatada mesmo né
é difícil dificilmente falava sobre né o
que ela estava sentindo
ela começou a freqüentar o posto de
saúde ela e ela toda semana com dor de
cabeça e até ele se tornou tão freqüente
começou a achar ela de chata
hipocondríaca que a gente não falava
diretamente papel mas a gente pensava lá
vende nova dona joana época a secretaria
de saúde contratada ela final ela vem
mais aqui do que a gente e aí teve um
dia que eu parei pra esse gente ouvir a
dona joana hoje eu vou falar para ela a
senhora dona joana não dá pra senhora
vem aqui toda semana eu preciso também
atender outras pessoas só está pode
estar ocupando o lugar de pessoas mais
viável e aí nesse dia foi o dia que eu
percebi um dos meus primeiros erros como
médica
eu não ouvi a dona joana ea dor de
cabeça dela na verdade era um pedido de
socorro porque ela sofria de violência
doméstica em casa então foi aquele
momento que eu comecei a aprender a
escutar né escutar que alguma coisa bem
rara entre os médicos têm um estudo
clássico de 1984 de beckman franca o que
mostra que nós médicos depois de
perguntar o motivo da consulta
a gente tem de interromper as pessoas em
18 segundos
a gente realmente não deixa as pessoas
falarem e porque a gente faz isso né
eu tenho trabalhado em uma comunidade da
zona rural há três anos e eu já tenho um
mapa mental na minha cabeça das casas
que eu preciso visitar em outubro que
são as casas claro em que os quintais
tem excelente jogo de cadeiras no
quintal né
nunca escondi meu amor por essa frutinha
e as pessoas já começaram a perceber
isso eu sempre ganho as sacolas de
jabuticaba em outubro mas durante as
nossas visitas nas casas das pessoas
a gente sempre tem aquele momento de
vistoriar a casa depois de historiar o
quintal vez tem um foco de dengue
essa força está na distância correta da
casa
naquele momento eu aproveito nesta a
deixa e fala mas este jogo de cabeça
e ele eu não estou mais com menos soja
butt cabo com o meu paciente
eu tô com medo jabuticaba uma pessoa o
seu joão e eu estou conhecendo a
essência mais pura de são joão no lugar
mais íntimo que pode existir que a casa
dele ea gente conhecer a casa ea vida
das pessoas é uma coisa muito importante
na medicina de família eu estava sentado
ali do lado no moça e ela falando tem
gente que não tem banheiro em casa eu
fui não acho que vou contar outra
história
eu tinha um adolescente que ela evacuava
nas calças 13 anos e ainda atuava nas
calças ea gente eu ia ea psicóloga
sentamos né e decidimos começar um
tratamento com ela que a cada vez que
ela conseguisse usar o banheiro
a gente teria uma fichinha para ela no
caso a família daria uma ficha para ela
uma recompensa e se ela como as 15
fichinha
a mãe dela levar ela para tomar um
sorvete ea premiar a ela com alguma
coisa ea gente né passou um tempo longe
dessa família e um dia eu fui visitar e
adivinha obra não tinha banheiro da casa
não tinha banheiro não tinha força e
eles faziam as necessidades num buraco
no quintal
então a gente precisa de qual o
tratamento a realidade das pessoas então
é importante a gente dentro das casas e
conhecer as famílias e tem um outro caso
de é dessa importância de conhecer a
família de uma paciente tinha ela se
assumiu homossexual para a família e
ninguém aceitou
é o pai não aceitou queria expulsar de
casa
desenvolver o transtorno de pânico a mãe
começou a freqüentar o posto com
freqüência cheia de dores pelo corpo
todo
sem muita explicação essas dores ea
menina começou a abrir um quadro
depressivo e eu não pude tratá los
individualmente porque ali era uma
questão familiar
então a gente precisou fazer um
tratamento envolvendo essa questão
delicada para conseguir que todos
saíssem dessa porque se eu tratasse eles
individualmente o que acontecer eles vão
começar tomando remédio para dom
dali a pouco desencadearia uma insônia
ea gente estaria agora no outro remédio
para dormir depois voltou a acordar
daqui a pouco o outro para energia daqui
aponta outra fila pra ser feliz ea gente
não tenha felicidade encapsulado que eu
saiba
então com esses anos de experiência de
muitas histórias acumuladas dentro da
medicina de família e com esse
amadurecimento que eu né passei
a página do facebook também amadureceu
comigo eu criei também um canal no
youtube produzir vídeos e eu procurei
fazer diferente é o que eu queria eu
queria pensar que o que eu posso fazer
apesar de todas as adversidades que nós
profissionais de saúde encaramos
principalmente nós que estamos sistema
único de saúde
falta estrutura precária falta de
insumos sobrecarga profissional como
transformar um pacote negativo é o
positivo então pensava que profissional
possa ser apesar de isso tudo é o que a
falta de luvas
não é da minha alçada resolver mas o que
eu posso fazer
apesar da falta de luvas é um pensamento
muito mais transformador
então eu pensei sempre gerir melhor os
meus recursos meus insumos e assim eu
consegui fazer a minha parte e o canal
então que antes era um conteúdo de
revolta é de denúncias por coisas que
nem que eu não gostava eu comecei com a
criar conteúdo educativo de saúde e
educação é algo realmente muito
enriquecedor pra gente tem uma história
um c parábola que houve uma vez que uma
senhora queria a saber tudo
ela entrou dentro da caverna de um guru
e falou olha eu só saio daqui quando eu
souber tudo e todo dia ele ia lá e
depois uma pilha de livros lopes ela
estudar e todo dia ele voltava lá e
perguntava e aí já sabe tudo ela não
ainda não
ele pegava uma vareta daquela na cabeça
dela
no outro dia a mesma coisa já aprendeu
tudo não ainda não
bareta na cabeça até que um dia ele
voltou lá fez a mesma pergunta teve a
mesma resposta
mas na hora que ele foi bater com a mão
na cabeça ela reclamam impediu até agora
você se formou
agora você já percebeu que você não tem
como saber tudo é impossível mas pelo
menos agora também você aprendeu a se
defender não sente dor então a educação
o conhecimento é algo infinito mas o
caminho que a gente traça para alcançar
muito legal é muito interessante e com
isso eu espero receber vários convites
para comer jabuticaba em outubro
obrigada
[Aplausos]